Unglaublich die medizin hat jahrhunderte ein organ übersehen und es ist nicht irgendein organ sondern ein komplettes
Gefäßsystem die blutbahn bot alles über das jetzt in klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja es ist geschehen violett ihr habt
Whatsapp so gewünscht und hier sind sie die violetten haare zur feier von zweieinhalb millionen views auf youtube
auf dienstag haben können das jetzt noch in der story sehen linke ist in der video beschreibung zum thema wie bitte die medizin hat seit
Jahrhunderten ein komplettes gefäßsystem, im körper übersehen wie konnte das passieren
Konkret geht es um das
intern stets in den zwischenraum mit diesen auch bindegewebe genannten zellen konnte die medizin bisher nichts anfangen aber
Darin verbirgt sich wohl ein komplettes system mit einer unbekannten flüssigkeit entdeckt wurde ist bei der untersuchung mit einem neuartigen
endoskop bei der untersuchung an der new york university school of medicine fiel
im gallengang ein netzwerk vieler mit flüssigkeit gefüllte hohlräume auf das in keinem fach buch beschrieben ist
Nie leise von der school of medicine untersuchte weiter und stieß achtung
Im ganzen körper auf dieses system von dam bis zur haut überall dort ist es zu finden
wo sich gewebe bewegt zusammengedrückt wird oder pulsiert in der medizin war schon lange klar dass irgendwo
Im körper noch zusätzliche flüssigkeit sein müsse nur gefunden hat sie niemand es wurde irgendwo in den zwischenräumen
vermutet zahlreiche funktionen könnte das neu gefundene system haben
körpereigene abwehr eine art dämpfer funktion für organe und anderes gewebe und der schutz vor
Alterungsprozessen aber wie kann es sein dass. Im einundzwanzigsten
Jahrhundert ein solch riesiges system einfach immer noch übersehen werden konnte ich finde das total
Verrückt und die erklärung ist ebenso ich sage mal bescheuert denn gewebe wird ja schon seit menschengedenken
unter dem mikroskop untersucht der casus knaxus
liegt in der behandlung der gewebeproben vor dem mikroskop ihren jeweils wird das gewebe nämlich so behandelt dass das
investitions behandlung zerstört wird die kanäle kollabieren zur unkenntlichkeit das system ist verschwunden zitat
unsere entdeckung hat das potenzial
dramatische fortschritte in der medizin herbeizuführen unter anderem könnt ihr die analyse interstitial
Flüssigkeit ein wertvolles diagnose werkstatt werden so kaiser das ist wirklich der wahnsinn
Krebs könnte in zukunft besser therapiert werden oder das bilden von
metastasen komplett unterbunden werden cellulite könnte vielleicht der vergangenheit angehören und und und absoluter wahnsinn
Wenn er als erstes neues dazu
Und da wird es in zukunft oder bald schon eine menge infos geben und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
Whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert und ihr bekommt direkt auch ein kleines goodie
seid gespannt der direkte draht zu mir einfach mehr drauf kriegen und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter auch dafür. Draufklicken kunst organe aus dem 3d drucker kunst vagina
erfolgreich implantiert ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran